20 HOLDS
. EKBLAD TAKES A SH A
HAMBURGER.
>> Steve: BUT YOU CAN'T LEAVE
YOUR SEAT , BECAUSE YOU'REON HI
HAS GOT A
>> Steve: VEG DEMO BREAKS
>> Randy: MARCHMENT GETS INTO
FRONT.
HE MOVES, HE SHOOTS AT 1-0.GOES
ANTON WAS ABLE TO GET THE PLAY.
HE SHOTS THE PUCK FORMER TEAM.
HE MAKES ON THE
ROAD LAST SEASON FOR THEM, HAS
BEEN HERE IS WHWHWAS
TERRIFIC.
HUGE CONGRATS FROM ALL OF US ST
BARKOV, SHORTHANDED.
SCORES. GREAT IDEA, THOUGH. UTE
AT THE REFEREE IN THE WAKE OF
THIS.
>> Daryl: RG. GOING LOW
WEEGAR  HAS THE PUCKTYING
FOR MORE THAN TWO MINUTES.
FINALLY RESULTSTHE LEAD.
IS UNDERWAY.
SPINNING AROUND YOU WILL FAR PO
FLORIDA EXTENDS THEIR
HE WILL GO OFF
FROM HUBERDEAU.
HE HAS BEEN ON
WILL SEND IT TOWARD THE NETMORE
PANTHERS NEED IT 1-0. AARON EKB
, BABY.
COMPANY.
NO REBOUND.
SWALLOWED UP
>> Ed:
FORSLING WITH THE GOAL.
HERE HE IS BACK
>> Ed: JONATHAN HUBERDEAU.
ARE YOU KIDDING ME?  FOR FLORID
IS GOING TO GO BACK BEHIND THE
NET THE PATIENT'S OF  PASS IT R
WHY NOT TRY
BOTH OF THE FLORIDA TEAMS.
IT IS NOT EASY.
CLEARED TO CENTER ICE.
TRYING TO FIGHT THROUGH THE
TRAFFIC.
>> Ed: UNBELIEVABLE.
JUST RELENTLESS ON THE PUCK.
YOU CAN SEE GAME.
>> DENIGRATE JOB SCORING FIRST.
OF LATE.
THERE ON .
IT MAKES IT VERY DIFFICULT FOR
COLUMBUS TOGETHER POSSESSION
OVER
THAT. ESE GUYS ARE RUTHLES
OFFENSIVE ZONE.
YOU CAN SEE, THEY THE BOARDS.
NOW IT'S
FLPUTS IN OUT IN FRONT AND THEY
SCORE.
IN   HORN
QUIST THERE.
HE SLIDES IT, THEN COMES BACK
TO WEAKER HEAR.
YOU CAN THEY DID WHEN THEY GOT
CARRYOVER EFFECT TO KEEP THAT
THIS GROUP.
ONSIDE, BUMPED NOW BY AND
MARKSTROM THERE, WITH AN
OPPORTUNITY THERE TO GET IT
SO RUSHED AHEAD BYTY ON
THIS POWER PLAY.
HE HELD ONTO THE PUCK IT.
COMPLETELY LOOKS LIKEEN FRONT.
VERHAEGHE A COUPLE LOOKS
TONIGHT A LOT CLOSER
BARKOV SHOT CLOCKED.
BOUNCED
BATTLE.
GAME, BOBROVSKY ANOTHER HOT
GOALIE T RIGHTED THE SHIP FOR
HIMSELF THIS YEAR AND BEEN
IT I
PUCK IN BEHIND THE GOAL.
POOLMAN THERE, DUMUM HEAD.
NOW HERE'S THE THE ROAD.
THEY HAVE 21 WINS AT HOME.
SEATTLE GAME NUMBEGRUBAUER'S
PAD.
I BELIEVE THAT HIT LEY SHEAHAN.
HUBERDEAU THINKS ABOUT IT.
ALL THE WAY AS
ON THENNI GOURDE DOES THE RIGHT
THING.
GOES DOWN, TRIES TO BLOCK THATI.
HIS FIRST GAME OF THE SEASON.
DEFLECTION, SCORES!ES DOWN TO
SUPPORT THAT PUCK.
OVERSUPPORT AND LEAVES HIGH ICE
OPEN.E WITH HIS BODY.
SEPARATES THE MAN.
HE WINS THE PUCK AND
>> Kevin: TWO GOALS IN 17 GAMES
COMING INTO TONIGHT.
HE'S CAN
AND JONAT
>> Kevin: UNREAL ACTION AS I
TALKED E SHIFT.
AND FINALLY DOES GET ONE PAST
CONNOR H
>> Kevin: THAT WAS DEFLECTED OFF
SAMBERG SKATE.
ENTERING THE OFFENSIVE ZONE.
THIS IS EARLIER WHERE LUNDELL
WHAT A PLAY BY THE CAPTAIN
THAT'S SOME NICE WORK THEREBY
STEPHENSON.
NOW STEPHENSON MOVES AHEAD.HT.
BENNETT WITH A CAREER-HIGH, 19
>> Steve: PIETRANGELO AND
>> Randy: THE PURSUIT AND THE
HARASSMENT BY FOR
VEGAS.
THE NET IS4-1. AND THE PANTHERS
HE WILL SHOOT IN AND GO AFTER O
UNREAL.  IN
SHARP DEFENSE AND ALEKSANDER
BARKOV WITH THAT BIG BODY
THE MOST IN THE NHL.CE THEY SLA
MASON GETS THE BI
THE PANTHERS.
AND YOU COULD NOT DRAW IT UP  A
GAME-WINNING GOAL. HIGH
GUDAS GETS A SKATE ON IT THEN
BOUNCES ONE OFF INTO THE CORNER
AFTER KEEPING IT IN OFF THE CRO
ELVIS'S ARM AND THA THE
GOAL TANDLE IT.
THEY'RE TRYING TO GET PUCKS OUT
BUT CREDIT MARCHMENT AGAIN.
WHAT A PLAY HERE ASIN.
NOW EKBLAD, HUBERDEAU, UP HIGH
TOP OF THE CIRCLE WITH A WRIST
RIGHT SIDE AND HE'S OPEN, REA B
FLORIDA LINE. YOU KNOW, THEO
AWAY, AND THE COUNTER IS
MARCHMENT AGAIN, THIS LIN
VERHAEGHE.
CENTERS.
BENNETT, SAM BENNETT FROM THE
CORNER IN FRONT, TIPPETT ABLE P.
>> Jody: HOW ABOUT LUNDELL?
HE'S GOT 3 ASSISTS.
THERE, MIDDLE OF THE ICE AND
GOES TOP CHECK